Jesse always surprises me she's great in
whatever she's doing and AR is always a
chameleon uh from playing something
dramatic to something comedic but who
have never seen both of them in
something romantic right so I was really
hoping for this romantic chemistry that
they will have on screen and the movie
is about her own decisions and how you
can escape from a relationship that the
society tells you that it's perfect and
move on in your life and find something
that makes you feel more real even when
you are moving a nail and you are
feeling the pain but at the same time
you are feeling something real sometimes
you have to to sacrifice something in
order to find love and love sometimes is
painful but it's something that we need
so much in our life